[Musique]
combien de plants d'arbres faut-il pour
remplacer les arbres disparu chaque
année au québec un arbre coupé un arbre
planté ce n'est pas toujours
indispensable au québec 80 % de la forêt
se reconstitue par elle-même quand
l'arbre et récolter les jeunes pousses
on laisse passer la lumière est
essentielle pour devenir des adultes
mais si la coupe est importante ou s'il
arrive un feu ou une épidémie d'insectes
il faut aider la nature
le ministère des forêts de la faune et
des parcs distribuer gratuitement 130
millions de plants d'arbres par annie
destinés au reboisement dans les forêts
publiques et privées et dans la grande
majorité des cas ce sont des plans de
résineux par exemple en 2016 les
pépinières ont livré 67 millions
d'épinette noire 27 millions d'épinette
blanche et 25 millions de pin gris
de plus à travers cette masse de jeunes
plants de conifères québec a produit un
million de feuillus à bois dur comme
l'érable le chêne et le ferai
le ministère des forêts a déjà livré
trois cents millions de plants
forestiers de reboisement deux fois plus
qu'actuellement
c'était avant les années 90 avant
l'arrivée des nouvelles pratiques
sylvicoles et la production de plants
qui donne des arbres de forte dimension
[Musique]